wollte eigentlich über dieser
katastrophe sprechen die sich im zwei
flugstunden von uns entfernt vollzieht
in der ukraine und jetzt bin ich bis so
ein geordert worden mit dieser wichtigen
sachen wie ohrfeigen für stars ich finde
dass einschließlich meine eigene
existenz vollkommen unerträglich wir
erleben einen massenmord in echtzeit wir
erleben barbara auf allen kanälen etwas
was es früher nicht gab weder beim
untergang der titanic noch bei den
deportationen in den deutschen
konzentrationslagern
und jetzt erleben wir dass alles live
und
widerstand dagegen fängt an zu erodieren
ich merke das so an den ersten artikeln
oder überlegungen immer gefragt wird ob
es nicht besser wäre wenn die ukraine
kapitulieren dann wird das blutvergießen
beendet ich krieg inzwischen massenweise
briefe die von leuten putin muss
wirklich in der tat viele troller hier
haben von leuten das russische vorgehen
vollkommen richtig finden ich weiß nicht
wie man in einem land wie dem bundesrat
in der bundesrepublik leben kann das
wirklich auf friedlicher koexistenz
basiert und dann emotional sich mit
putin
identifizieren kann und das tun sehr
viel zumindest mehr als ich je
angenommen habe weil ich dieses thema
noch nie gearbeitet habe und das ist ich
sage es noch mal es ist ungeheuerlich
wir kriegen das alles mit wir sehen ist
und wir debattieren darüber ob wir einen
atomkrieg riskieren wollen wenn wir den
himmel über der ukraine für die angriffe
der russen sperren meiner es muss noch
etwas geben zwischen atomkrieg und
totale kapitulation und damit die
verlassenheit mit der willy tausenden
von toten hinnehmen wie es mir
unheimlich es mir deswegen unheimlich
weil ich mir vorstellen kann wie sich
die europäischen regierungen und des
karnevalsvereins nato verhalten würden
wenn die gefahr bisschen weiter sich in
den westen bewegt island ist das
sozusagen das gebot der stunde
hier geschlagen hat und ich kann dann
nur wenn sie gestatten willst in georgia
zitieren er hat mal den klugen satz
gesagt viele kluge sätze und gerade
besonders klug hat gesagt er ist jemand
der ein krokodil füttert in der hoffnung
es werde in als letzten fressen und das
steht uns bevor wenn sie heute um den
nächsten tagen und wochen nicht den
kleinen helfen diesen massenmord zu
entkommen
also ich habe nicht den eindruck dass
wir den krieg in der ukraine mit
gelassenheit wahrnehmen ich nehme im
gegenteil sehr viel solidarität war
menschen die auf die straße gehen die
demonstrieren und auch versuchen gerade
in den ukrainischen flüchtlingen die
hier ankommen zu helfen weil ich das
politische ende und wir haben ja auch
gesprächen auch politisch von einer
zeitenwende selbst die spd ist jetzt ja
auf die idee gekommen dass auch eine
bundeswehr finanziert werden muss und
ausgestattet werden muss ordentlich
insofern teile ich ihre ihrer analyse in
teilen leider nicht aber ich gebe ihnen
recht das thema des information ist ein
ganz wichtiges thema ist ja auch ein
thema was mich bewegt wenn wir auch
gleich noch hören und sie hatten ja
interessanterweise auch noch in ihrer in
ihrem passus den sie eingereicht haben
zum thema haben sie auch noch mal das
thema rechts radikalität aufgeworfen
alles klar das finde ich tatsächlich ein
ganz interessantes thema weil es ganz
oft parallelen gibt also das ist so
meine wahrnehmung twitter ich hab nicht
mal zum thema impfpflicht geäußert
politisch und hatte dann ganz viel
plötzlich zum thema ukraine krieg unter
diesem unter diesem beitrag und
umgekehrt auch also offensichtlich ist
das ja ein milieu das darauf anspringt
und das finde ich ganz information quer
auch gleich mit ihrem thema ist aber
aber long einer rückfrage auch an sehr
bruder wenn sie sagen sie finde es
schlimm wie wir damit umgehen mit dem
krieg was könnte deutschland denn anders
machen oder die deutsch also was ihr
lösungsvorschlag schon ein wort zur
klärung ich war neulich in einem zug
davon mit flüchtlingen war und sie war
wirklich tief gerührt und überrascht von
der hilfsbereitschaft die sie an jeder
station aus neuer abgespielt hat in
polen und später auch in deutschland
ganz viele junge leute die helfen die
sich der flüchtlinge annahmen sehr
eindrucksvoll das waren einer der
wenigen momente wo ich bei einer gesagt
hätte ich bin stolz ein deutscher zu
sein aber was können wir machen schauen
sie die sache ist was haben wir nicht
gemacht heute in der weltweit
hervorragende artikel ich habe vergessen
von wem darüber wie frau lambrecht die
irgendwie durch einen wunderbaren zufall
der geschichte in das amt des
verteidigungsministers gekommen ist
vielleicht weil ich das angebot
abgelehnt habe wie frau lambrecht vier
wochen lang eine entscheidung über
lieferung von waffen an die ukraine
verzögert hingehalten hat also wenn sich
das normale gemeine volk wahnsinnig gut
verhält fährt die politik ein halter
kurs und wenn sie olaf scholz bei anne
will vor drei tagen gesehen haben dann
wissen sie wie man fragen nicht
beantwortet ich habe verständnis dafür
er kann vieles nicht auf den tisch legen
und schon gar nicht das was viele
journalisten wissen wollen auf welchen
wegen die waffen in die ukraine kommen
und ähnliches schon die fragen sind
albern aber es gab eine verzögerung in
der politischen klasse würde es
wahrscheinlich parteiübergreifend weil
die ansicht vor hersteller von
politischen welt dass die ukraine in
drei tagen überrollt sein wird und dann
löst sich das verhältnis eben auf dem
wege der stärke und das ist bis jetzt
nicht eingetreten und dann herr palmer
hat die politik ein hinhalte kurs ist
dass gerade der kurs wie man die politik
in der ukraine krise beschreiben sollte
darwin selbst sagen das wundert sie aber
ich mache mir da keinen mutter und ich
bin ehrlich gesagt
mit dem gefühl nach oben macht da jetzt
konfrontiert
und ich stelle fest dass ich von
außenpolitik und dem was da abläuft so
wenig verstehe dass ich einfach nicht
sagen kann was er richtig oder falsch
ist schon weil ich in der lage bin zu
beurteilen was die reaktion der anderen
seite sein wird und deswegen halte ich
mich da zurück ich kann das wirklich
will ich das vernünftig das ist nicht
seine politische frage ist eine frage
der eigenen konsequenz sie können nicht
eine politik machen der auf dem nie
wieder passiert und das nie wieder meint
die gräueltaten der nazis aber nicht die
gräueltaten die jetzt im namen von putin
und leider eines großen teils der
russischen bevölkerung begangen werden
das ist keine politik da geht es um
praktizierter gelebte angewandter
menschlichkeit und daran mangelt es ich
denke was man schon feststellen kann ist
dass die ampel regierung sehr zögerlich
gehandelt hat insbesondere wenn man es
vergleicht mit anderen anderen ländern
wie beispielsweise großbritannien war
sehr viel schneller beim thema
waffenlieferungen und wir haben uns hier
in deutschland noch für 5000 helme ab
gefeiert und gleichzeitig haben wir ein
bundeskanzler der sagt er war
vorbereitet hat irgendwie ganz viele
schubladen bei sich wo überall
vorbereitungspläne drin sind aber
offenbar war er nicht vorbereitet genug
um auf die situation entsprechend
angemessen zu reagieren
also da frage ich mich schon was stimmt
denn jetzt eigentlich also nicht nur wo
ist scholz sondern was will scholz und
wer ist scholz man muss ihm zugutehalten
dass man in solchen situationen niemand
gerechnet hat und das ist mir schon ja
gesagt ja sagt ja vielleicht hatte den
schlüssel zum schreibtisch im boliden
lassen konnte nicht mehr realistisch
fand es auch sehr seltsam dass alle von
dem abzug der amerikaner aus afghanistan
dermaßen überrascht waren wir haben dort
wir haben dort geheimdienst mitarbeiter
werden dort stiftungen vertretungen und
niemand war mit den verhältnissen
vertrauten dasselbe jetzt seit 16 jahren
die ganze regierungszeit von frau merkel
fahren wir einen schmusekurs gegenüber
russland nicht nur auch die nur dem iran
und dann sind wir ganz überrascht dass
eine diktatur sich wie eine diktatur
benimmt was wäre eine überraschung wie
schnee in den sommerferien und das das
erleben wir jetzt in eine eindeutigkeit
die ich gerne vermieden hätte und das
ist wahrscheinlich keine
parteipolitische frage und noch mal ich
verstehe schon dass sonst nicht alles
sagen kann auch nicht alles sagen will
aber jeder tag der verzögerung ist ein
tacker vieler menschen das leben kostet
und ich denke ich denke man könnte auch
mit einem russen ein geschäft machen
weil sie wissen wahrscheinlich auch es
gibt eine zusammenarbeit zwischen israel
und den russen über die über die
aktionen über den syrischen oder unter
dem syrisch im himmel ist war er fliegt
dann ganz unverschämt ganz oft einsätze
und schaltet gewisse gefahrenquellen aus
und die russen wissen das weil sich
israel mit russland abspricht
vernünftigerweise möchte keiner ein
flugzeug des anderen erwischen wieso ist
das in der ukraine nicht möglich kann
die nato nicht per diskreter fühler
ausstrecken und sagen den russen sagen
ihr fliegt da jetzt nicht drüber aber
ihr könnt es eine tolle propaganda
machen wie euch gehen uns gestellt hat
wir wissen es nicht aber das müsste doch
gehen vor allem das primat müsste sein
die rettung von menschenleben und das
ist es nicht